just a few hours ago a host of AI
industry leaders experts and academics
put out this 22-word statement on making
AI safety a global priority the
so-called statement on AI risk brought
together for the first time all the
current AGI lab leaders that's people
like Sam Altman Ilya satskova Demus
hasabis and Dario Amadeus and two of the
three founders of deep learning itself
Joshua bengio and Jeffrey Hinton here is
what the statement said mitigating the
risk of Extinction from AI should be a
global priority alongside other societal
level risks such as pandemics and
nuclear war it is now almost impossible
to deny that this is now the consensus
view among AI experts let's first look
at the Preamble then break down the
statement and show you the signatories
they say that AI experts journalists
policy makers and the public are
increasingly discussing a broad spectrum
of important and Urgent risks from AI
even so it can be difficult to voice
concerns about some of the advanced ai's
most severe risks the succinct statement
below aims to overcome this obstacle and
open up discussion it is also meant to
create common knowledge of the growing
number of experts and public figures who
also take some of advanced ai's most
severe risks seriously the first point
is that the statement is in a way
optimistic it says we can mitigate this
risk perhaps not eliminate it but
mitigate it reduce the risk second it
says we should do this globally and
that's not just among all the different
AGI Labs almost all of which sign these
statement but also between countries in
that vein there were quite a few
prominent signatories from China and the
third point that I'd make is that they
put it on a par with pandemics and
nuclear war toward the end of the video
I'll show you that's not as far-fetched
as it sounds but anyway who actually
signed this statement let's find out we
have two of the three founders of deep
learning that's Jeffrey Hinton and
Joshua bengio the third founder was
yanlichun and we'll touch on him later
in the video all three of those won the
most prestigious Accolade in computer
science which is the Turing award then
we have three of the CEOs of the top AGI
Labs Sam Altman Demis hasabis and Dario
amade of openai Google deepmind and
anthropic none of those signed the pause
letter but they did sign this statement
and actually as interestingly for me so
did Ilya satsukova who I see as the
brains behind open AI he of course also
worked with Jeffrey Hinton on deep
learning and is widely regarded as the
smartest guy in machine learning you
will also notice so many Chinese
signatories especially from xinhua
University which I've actually visited
in China it's one of their leading
universities that's a really encouraging
sign of cooperation between the west and
countries like China on AI and the list
of significant signatories goes on and
on and on these are senior people at the
top of Deep Mind anthropic and open Ai
and there are names like Stuart Russell
who wrote The Textbook on AI who also
signed the pause letter let me highlight
a few more names for you here you have
the CTO of Microsoft itself Kevin Scott
he's the guy who basically heads up the
partnership between openai and Microsoft
I think many people will miss his name
but I think it's particularly
significant that he also signed this
notice also the CEO of stability AI emad
mostacc the center for AI safety
coordinated this effort and I'll get on
to their eight examples of AI risk in a
moment but first let's pick out a few
more names you've got David Chalmers
Daniel Dennett Lex Friedman and Victoria
krakovna now together with the statement
the center for AI safety also puts out
this eight examples of AI risk I've read
almost every paper linked to in these
eight examples so I'm going to try to
summarize them fairly briefly because I
know not everyone will will be that
interested it starts by saying that AI
could be profoundly beneficial but also
present serious risks due to competitive
pressures before we get to the risks I
want to touch on some of the upsides
recently outlined by Demis hasabis and
these showcase what can happen if we get
this right we had sort of a golden
couple of years in some sense for AI for
science we've had lucky enough to have
many Nature and Science papers published
in all sorts of domains so from quantum
chemistry better DFT functions to
approximate Schrodinger's equation pure
mathematics we've solve some important
conjectures in topology with
collaborating with some brilliant
mathematicians who found working on
Fusion reactors with epfl on their test
Fusion reactor controlling the plasma in
real time in their Fusion reactors and
being able to hold the plasma safely in
place for for arbitrary amounts of time
being able to predict rainfall many
hours ahead and more accurately than
current meteorological models and then
in applications there's a ton of those
two we saved one of the any things we
did at Google was saving about 30 of the
cooling energy used to cool the massive
data centers at Google so there's a huge
energy saving and we're starting to
explore doing that across actual whole
power grids and this Echoes what Joshua
bengio said in a recent blog post which
is that we can build immensely useful AI
systems that are modeled after ideal
scientists and do not act autonomously
in the real world janlecon recently said
that we would never give current llms
agency there is a a flaw in current Auto
reversive lens so there is no persistent
memory first of all but second of all
you cannot control the system you cannot
impose constraints on it like be factual
be understandable by a 13 year old and
that makes them very difficult to to
control and steer and so that creates
some fears because people are kind of
extrapolating if we let those systems do
whatever we connect them to internet and
they can do whatever they want they're
going to do crazy things and stupid
things and perhaps dangerous things and
we're not going to be able to control
them and they're going to escape Troll
and they're going to become intelligent
just because they're bigger right and
that's nonsense first of all because
this is not the type of system that we
are going to give agency to that was a
week before this paper was published on
the results of giving agency to current
large language models the paper showed
that current llms with agency are able
to utilize the learn skill library in
Minecraft to solve novel tasks from
scratch zooming into the diagram you can
see how this Voyager model outperforms
reflection which I've talked about in
previous videos and auto GPT and it
discovers new items and skills
continually by self-driven exploration
significantly outperforming the bass
lines indeed Andre carpathy responded to
this study saying very clear that AGI
will Mega transform Society but still
will have but is it really reasoning how
do you define reasoning oh it's only
predicting the next token can machines
really think and he called that armchair
philosophy previously though even Yan
lacun has admitted some risks saying you
know it's like rockets you test it it
blows up you tweak it and then try again
I'm not sure I'm okay with an attempt at
AGI blowing up the first time but I'll
leave that up to you to decide so what
are these eight examples of AI risk that
the center for AI safety to organize the
statement list out they say that AI
systems are rapidly becoming more
capable they can power autonomous
weapons promote misinformation and
conduct cyber attacks as we've seen they
are increasingly able to act
autonomously now there is so much to say
here and I've read each of these but I
want to keep it to just the highlights
so let's move on to the first example
weaponization malicious actors could
repurpose AI to be highly destructive
presenting an existential risk in and of
itself and increasing the probability of
political destabilization they talk
about aerial combat and then building
chemical weapons which I mentioned in my
previous video on governing super
intelligence then they mentioned
developing AIC systems for automated
cyber attacks they mentioned military
leaders discussing giving AI systems
decisive control over nuclear silos I'm
going to quickly try to demonstrate why
that kind of autonomous AI might not be
such a good idea I want you to meet a
hero stanislav Petrov he was the duty
officer at the command center the OKO
nuclear early warning system when the
system reported that a missile had been
launched from the US followed by up to
five more Petrov judged the reports from
the system to be a false alarm and his
subsequent decision to disobey orders
against Soviet military protocol is
credited with having prevented an
erroneous retaliatory nuclear attack on
the U.S which it says could have
resulted in a large-scale nuclear war
which could have wiped out half the
population of these countries involved
an investigation later confirmed that
the Soviet satellite warning system the
machines behind it had indeed
malfunctioned I would not have wanted
that system to be or autonomous then we
hear that gpt4 was able to autonomously
conduct experiments and synthesize
chemicals in a real world lab again I
covered that paper at the time and then
linking back to Petrov they say an
accident with an automated retaliation
system could rapidly escalate and give
rise to a major war but that unlike
previous weapons AI systems with
dangerous capabilities could be easily
proliferated through digital means
hopefully you can start to see why we
need to balance risks with opportunities
but let's move on to misinformation I
think we can all agree that we already
have too much misinformation so let's
move on to the next one which is proxy
gaming this has already been showcased
in the social dilemma where AI
recommender systems are trained to
maximize watch time and click rate
metrics and this can lead people into
Echo chambers that helps develop extreme
beliefs in order to make those people
easier to predict by the AI recommender
systems so you might think it will be
simple just to tell the AI to promote
happiness or economic growth but that
might not work out as you intend next is
in feebleman if we delegate more and
more tasks to machines we become
increasingly dependent on them and here
they actually mention the film Wally
which if you remember the ending
features this quite comically imagine if
it becomes well known that companies led
by AI CEOs bring in more profit well
then it wouldn't take long for all
companies to be under immense pressure
to make their managers and CEOs Ai and I
know what many people will be thinking
couldn't that be an improvement on the
current system and while I know exactly
what you mean in the current world
realistically it would still be the
people owning the company that would
derive the profit and while the ultimate
answer may be some form of universal
basic income we do need some time to set
that up and the current accelerated AI
arms race doesn't give us much of that
time next is value lock-in which links
very much to the last point about giving
small groups of people a tremendous
amount of power in other words if you
want massive change to the way the world
Works giving current leaders AGI might
not be the best way of doing it they say
that such AI systems might enable
regimes to enforce narrow values through
pervasive surveillance and oppressive
censorship next is emergent goals this
is sometimes called misalignment and
we've already seen many AI agents
develop goals such as self-preservation
and you can see why even a system
designed to do good might have that goal
you can't do good and help the world if
you're shut down so it makes sense that
even the most benign AI might want to
preserve itself and to take actions
including through deception to make sure
that it's not shut off and this is not
just Theory the accompanying academic
paper natural selection favors AIS over
humans gave this example agents could
behave One Way during testing and
another way once they are released to
win the war game diplomacy which many of
you will have heard of players need to
negotiate J form alliances and become
skilled at Deception to win control of
the game's economic and Military
resources AI researchers have trained
metas AI agent Cicero an expert
manipulator to do the same in summary it
would cooperate with a human player then
change its plan and backstab them in
Future these abilities could be used
against humans in the real world again
that's not because they're malevolent or
hate humans it just makes sense it's
smart to do so this brings us neatly on
to deception and they give the great
example of Volkswagen who programmed
their engines to reduce emissions only
when being monitored and future AI
agents could similarly switch strategies
when being monitored and take steps to
obscure their deception from monitors
once deceptive AI systems are cleared by
their monitors or once such systems can
overpower them these systems could take
a treacherous turn and irreversibly
bypass human control I talked a bit more
about that point of when AI might become
deceptive in my previous video on
governing super intelligence it is a key
debate in the AI alignment Community
about whether models will become
deceptive before they become helpful for
alignment but finally we have power
seeking behavior and this example ends
on this dark note building power seeking
AI is also incentivized because
political leaders see the Strategic
advantage in having the most intelligent
most powerful AI systems for example
Vladimir Putin has said whoever becomes
the leader in AI will become the ruler
of the world so those were the eight
examples and yes I would have signed
this statement but I'm not a significant
figure so I can't anyway let me know in
the comments if you agree that this
should be a global priority and of
course you can also let me know if you
don't think it should be a global
priority my goal in this channel is to
cover both the risks and opportunities
so I'd love to hear from you whatever
your opinion is have a wonderful day